Alexa, acht Flaschen 72er
Chardonnay bestellen!
Chardonnay bestellen, sehr gerne!
Alexa, Smoking in die Reinigung
und die Hemden aufbügeln!
Smoking in die Reinigung und Hemden bügeln, sehr gerne!
Alexa! Lass mir ein heißes Bad ein!
Ein heißes Bad einlassen ...
Alexa, spiel entspannende Gitarrenmusik!
Alexa! Alexa! Was ist jetzt, Alexa? Entspannende Gitarrenmusik!
Ach, leck mich doch am A****! Was denn noch alles? Ich habe schließlich auch nur zwei Hände.
Und wenn du noch einmal Alexa zu mir sagst, dann haue ich dir eine runter.
Ich bin schließlich immer noch deine Mutter.
Und in Zukunft kannst du deinen ganzen Scheißdreck wieder schön alleine machen!
Du Rotzlöffel, du stinkfauler!
Aber, Mama!
Nichts ist mit "Mama". Lass mir ein heißes Bad ein, ich glaube, ich spinne!